hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down
all the latest in black clover
including the return of noel and some
other
overpowered characters the truth about
yuno
and noct's shadow magic and the
beginning
of the epic final battle of the entire
spade kingdom
saga all the pieces are moving into
place for an incredible showdown between
the dark triad on the one side
and the very strongest warriors from the
clover kingdom
on the other the action will only get
more intense from here
so let's dive into it if you enjoy the
blacklord content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime pro or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications it's annoying but you
got to go through the trouble of hitting
that bell and selecting the option that
says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a lot of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain black clover manga
spoilers
i'm talking about the very latest in the
manga so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the latest
installment of the story we are back
inside the captains and vice captains
meeting where knocked
explains that he can use his shadow
magic to sneak warriors from the clover
kingdom
into the spade kingdom and strike the
dark triad by surprise
noct is planning to target the dark
triad one by one
and he will use his shadow magic and his
detailed knowledge of the spade kingdom
to get
the job done however as i speculated in
my previous black clover video
knocked shadow magic cannot teleport an
infinite number of people
he can only take the strongest and most
important warriors
and jack instantly says that the choice
is obvious they can just take the magic
knight captains
and this is because of course the
captains are considered to be among the
strongest warriors
in the entire kingdom this isn't
entirely true though since characters
like julius and mario leona are stronger
than many captains
with that said in his current form
julius may not be strong enough
but they better freaking take mero leona
she absolutely
deserves to be on this mission if we
take into consideration raw power
and i think that we all can agree that
we need more mere leona
in our lives but as soon as jack
suggests
just taking the captains juno stands up
and begs the captains to bring him along
as well
jack says that there is no sense of
taking someone who already lost to xenon
in battle
but yuno desperately wants to save
captain william
and yuna wants to get even with xenon
for what he did to the golden dawn squad
we can't forget that xenon killed
multiple members
of the golden dawn squad and severely
injured many others
in that moment knocked suddenly asks
juno
about his real identity nacht
knows that a member of the spade
kingdom's resistance movement
the faction inside the kingdom that is
secretly fighting against the dark triad
recently came to the spade kingdom and
made contact with yuno nakt
is of course talking about ralph and the
fact that noct has this information
really speaks to the fact that he is an
excellent spy
i am sure that he possesses lots of
intel that could end up being critically
important for
this upcoming mission yuno then publicly
admits
that he is the rightful prince of the
spade kingdom
you know of the house grin burial the
magic knight captains and asta himself
are shocked to learn this
and their reaction makes perfect sense
of course but it's been so long since
that juno identity reveal happened that
i kind of forgot that most people still
don't know this fact
asta's reaction was particularly
interesting since he literally grew up
with juno
inside an orphanage in the forsaken
realm and now
suddenly he learns that juno was
actually a prince the whole time that is
pretty insane
juno says that ralph was a servant to
the former king of the spade kingdom so
he possesses crucial information
about the royal palace that could end up
being essential for the success of the
mission
yuno then goes on to say that beyond the
fact that he is the true heir to the
spate kingdom throne
it is also his duty as the golden dawn
vice captain to try his best to save his
captain
william von jens even though many
powerful people in the clover kingdom
lost faith in william after he allowed
pawtry to take over his body and wreak
havoc upon the capital juno explains
that a major reason why william lost to
xenon
was the fact that he was fighting xenon
while also doing his best to protect
all the other members of the golden dawn
william felt guilty about what poetry
had done
and so he felt obligated to protect all
of his fellow golden dawn members even
though this took his focus
away from the fight against xena and
that
is a big part of the reason why xenon
came out on top
and managed to capture william as a
result
juno feels indebted to william for
protecting his life
and the lives of many golden dawn
members and so yuno is committed to
rescuing william from the dark triad
even if that means risking his own life
in the process
juno vows to prove that the golden dawn
knights are the strongest squad
in the entire kingdom and he vows to
save william from the clutches
of the dark triad as yuno speaks
his mana surges wildly and we can see
that self is working on
building up as much mana as possible so
that they can ultimately defeat
xenon i have to say that juno's claim
that the golden dawn squad is the
strongest
is kind of total bs at this point
now that we've met knocked there is
absolutely no way that any squad can
mess
with the black bulls but whatever the
golden dawn does still have more stars
not that this actually means anything in
terms of their raw strength
but moving on knocked notices yuno's
determination
and his strength and he declares that he
doesn't hate
yuno as we know this is high praise
coming from nakht
since he claims to hate his own long
time friend and captain
yami presumably this means that nacht
will in fact allow yuno himself to
accompany him and asta
on the mission to rescue the captains
for his part
osta stays true to the essence of his
character
even though he is understandably shocked
to learn that juno is actually a prince
asta says that whether he is a prince of
the spade kingdom
or the vice captain of the golden dawn
you know is still you know
so asta will not treat his friend any
differently
and i loved this little moment with
hosta this is honestly one of the
reasons why i love asta as a character
the way that asta treats people doesn't
depend on their social status or their
family background
he treats everyone equally and he treats
everyone with respect
even when others fail to show him the
same kind of respect
the only people that osta loses his
temper around are people who are
genuinely evil
and hurting others in some way and so
the big mission will begin
in two days time and asked and you know
vowed to rescue their two captains
together
the final battle of this epic saga
is about to begin fugolian suggests that
they should request cooperation from the
hard kingdom
but the captains of the clover kingdom
have been unable to reach the heart
kingdom
since the previous day knocked confirms
that
all three members of the dark triad were
absent from the spade kingdom castle
yesterday which means that vanica likely
attacked the heart kingdom while xenon
and dante were trying to secure
william and yami asta knows that his
friends noel mimosa secretary
and others are currently inside the
heart kingdom
and so he shows genuine concern when he
hears this
with loro pechika now kidnapped i am not
sure if anyone from the heart kingdom
will be strong enough to join this
special strike force
but we'll have to wait and see meanwhile
the final panels of the chapter
suddenly take us to noel as you will
recall
we haven't actually seen noel since her
big fight with vanica
and the last time that we saw her vanica
had just taken off with loro pechika and
left noel and mimosa to deal with one of
her dark disciple
explosions the focus of the story then
shifted back to the fight between dante
and yami
and we didn't know what actually
happened to noel was she hurt in the
explosion
was she safe and what about mimosa and
sacre
it was actually a pretty major
cliffhanger now that i think about it
although it's safe to assume that all of
them survived because these are not the
type of characters who would just
die off screen now some nine chapters
later
we finally see noel again she wakes up
in an unknown place
and it's clear that she has been
unconscious for some time
as she looks at her surroundings she
realizes that pawtree and the other
surviving elves
are standing over her and that is how
this chapter ends
with the strong implication that the
elves saved noel
and that the elves might now team up
with the clover kingdom warriors
in order to defeat the dark triad and
their
demons this would actually make perfect
sense
the holy sephiroth is the polar opposite
of the
unholy cliffhoth so the elves and the
apostles of sephirah in particular
may hold some important secrets on how
to ultimately stop
the tree of cliffhoth i am definitely
excited to see this
secret mission get started and the final
battle of this saga is being built up
in a big way we are about to see knocked
juno asta and many other overpowered
mages
secretly infiltrating the spade kingdom
and taking on the dark triad
we might even see noel and the elves
joining in on the action
although we still don't know what
happened to noel mimosa and sakret
between chapters 255 and now what do you
guys think
are the elves about to join in the
battle against the dark triad
and if so what role do you think they
are going to play
is noel going to gain a major power up
that will allow her to join the mission
as well and finally
take on vanica and by the way what
happened to mimosa
and sacre definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black clover content on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime out
pro or you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications remember that you have
to go through the trouble of hitting the
bell and then selecting the option that
says
all if you don't do that youtube is
still going to bury a lot of our videos
even if you are subscribed feel free to
follow me on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
a disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world
acquired respect pate heffa jonathan
king
brandon aviles papa smurf emperor talk
who thomas jones kid mono and
admirath finally thank you to all of our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson kings
eldris anatoly kazotsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica califond hinokami and water
bonnie parks ratheora florian joni
garcia
steelers deadly saint and stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you